we interrupt with breaking news the
three white men charged with chasing and
killing ahmad arbury are found guilty of
murder i want to walk you through the
verdict because it varies for all three
men starting with travis mcmichael he
was found guilty on all charges as a
reminder this was a nine count
indictment this means he faces life in
prison moving on to greg mcmichael he is
found guilty on all charges except the
most egregious which is malice murder
and william r bryan was found guilty on
all except the two most egregious
charges again this means that all three
of those men were found guilty of murder
now for more analysis we're going to
bring in bloomberg news legal reporter
eric larson he's been reporting on this
case and he also just reported on the
written house trial which we'll be
discussing too eric thank you for
joining us on this breaking news story
tell me what your biggest takeaway is
right now
you know my my big takeaway from this is
that the jury in this case just did not
buy the self-defense defense that these
three men had put forward they claimed
that uh barbary was killed because they
had to defend themselves from him uh
even though they had chased him down in
two pickup trucks uh with two guns uh
while he was unarmed and just running
down the street um that really contrasts
with the kyle rittenhouse case of course
that you mentioned kyle writtenhouse
comes not guilty on all charges last
week um in shootings at a black lives
matter rally in wisconsin so he also
claims self-defense uh but really that
the jury did buy it in that case because
the evidence just showed
more accurately i suppose that he was uh
that he feared for his life so really
just two different very different
outcomes with a self-defense defense
right well we know that the jury also i
think it was just a couple hours before
the verdict came in asked to re-watch
the video what do you make of that how
big of an impact do you think that had
on the outcome here
you know honestly when we when we put
out a short story on them
re-watching those videos i really wasn't
sure which way that they were leaning um
just based on that because you know
really the video was used by both the
defense and the prosecution to make
their cases so it was really kind of
unclear
uh but we did see that the state used
the video very effectively to show just
really that arbory was he was an unarmed
man running down the street and you
could see over and over in these videos
these three men coming at him with two
trucks with guns and uh it just really
was very clear sort of what would happen
in those minutes yeah yeah and i know i
also want to mention that it wasn't
until the video of ahmad arbury's murder
came out to to the public that these
charges were were filed i'm curious and
also i should mention we are looking at
live pictures on the ground in brunswick
georgia from reaction of protesters and
individuals who were watching for this
verdict throughout the day and
throughout this entire trial eric going
back to you i know you just covered the
written house trial and you mentioned
that a little bit
what do you make of the very different
verdicts here do you attribute that
mainly to the self-defense argument or
is there something else going on here
no i absolutely do attribute that to the
self-defense argument because uh you
know regardless of what someone thinks
about what happened with kyle
rittenhouse in kenosha wisconsin the
video that was shown at that trial did
show
written how uh you know on the ground on
the in the streets sort of surrounded by
people who were chasing him uh they did
not
appreciate his presence there especially
armed uh you know
you could debate all day whether or not
they uh he should have been there at
that protest at all with that ar-15
style weapon which is obviously would be
intimidating to a lot of people there
especially in the world of mass
shootings we live in but but the video
just at the end of the day showed him
surrounded by people who were trying to
attack him essentially the way they
presented it to the jury it was a very
chaotic situation and he feared for his
life of course rittenhouse broke down on
the witness stand uh testifying in his
own defense talking about how scared he
was
um you know and in this case in georgia
um arbory mr arbor did not pose that
same kind of threat he was not chasing
those three men they were chasing him
uh in two trucks and you know those
aggravated assault counts were for
included assault with that truck that
they pen penned him pinned him in and
um and tried to carry out what they
later described as a at the citizen's
arrest
right i want to go back to the
specificity of the verdicts here because
they are different for all three of the
men involved what do you make of that
did that surprise you
uh you know it didn't actually surprise
me too much because um we really did see
that uh
uh even though they were all charged
with the same nine counts and and the
state argued that they were all guilty
on all of them they really they really
did leave some wiggle room there
for um the jury to consider different
weights of responsibility in a way i
mean we never know
we can't get into the heads of the
jurors we weren't in their deliberations
but clearly travis mcmichael he's the
one who told the trigger he fired three
shots from that shotgun and and killed
uh mr artery uh so it's it's not too
much uh it's not as surprising that he
would be found guilty of a malice murder
that the count one whereas the other two
men his father and and their neighbor
were found not guilty uh so even there
are several other murder counts there's
felony murders uh which would be murders
that uh deaths that resulted
while carrying out felonies of
aggravated assault so it's a little
complex they were all found guilty of
murder charges but it was really travis
mcmichael who is found guilty of the
most severe one here
i also want to look ahead with you
because obviously the state trial just
finished outside of sentencing but the
hate crimes trial begins in february how
could today's verdict play into that if
at all
you know that's a really good question
and and i'm not sure you would know that
the judge in in that case is going to
want to say that this has no bearing
whatsoever he'll want uh you know jurors
if they when it gets to trial to have uh
to really not take this into account at
all um you know that's always the
challenge facing judges and juries in in
any case but in a case that this high
profile and in which this federal case
will be happening after this one which
you know many many people will be
hearing about
uh you know the the defense teams will
probably argue um you know that there's
some sort of uh that the jury's been
tainted in some way by all of this media
attention and news um it's totally
unclear how far that might get them in
court in their defense um but they're
going to have a hard time i'm sure
finding a jury that
will be totally unbiased not a hard time
but they're going to have to be very
careful doing that
i i do want to mention a little part of
a statement that we just got from
senator warnock down in georgia he said
true justice looks like a young black
man not having to worry about being
harmed or killed while on a jog while
sleeping in his bed while living what
should be a very long life and he added
ahmad should be with us today going back
to you eric when do we expect to hear
more on on the sentencing here
uh you know i don't know the judge
hasn't set a date yet i imagine it'll
happen uh somewhat quickly
um you know that's gonna be the next uh
you know real thing to watch here
because the judge does have some some
leeway um on that malice murder char uh
charge um
they did not seek the death penalty the
state didn't seek the death penalty so
that's not an option but life uh he does
face life behind bars and the judge and
you know the law does say that the judge
has some um ability to offer a chance of
parole uh down the road but he'd have to
serve uh 30 years first but that so it
remains to be seen whether the judge
will do anything there
um but yeah there's going to be a range
of range here they all of the men face
potentially decades behind bars uh if
not life for travis mcmight mick
michaels yeah yeah looking at the
verdict for um william robbie bryan who
was found guilty of on all counts except
for those two most egregious what does
the timeline look like for for him in
terms of prison time
uh you know to be honest i haven't uh
calculated that up yet i'm not fair
enough i'm not quite sure so i don't
want to give you any inaccurate
information but yeah definitely he's
gonna he's in a in a better position
here and you asked earlier about whether
or not any of this was was surprising
and it
in particular him getting uh uh getting
off a little bit more easy here is not
too surprising because you know as his
defense uh team said at trial and in
their closing statements he you know he
was he didn't have a gun he was actually
the one who filmed the video that became
the sense you know central piece of
evidence he was filming from his phone
in his front seat yes you know the jury
found that he used his car to to block
artery and that that result helped
result in his death uh but he wasn't one
of the main aggressors it seems in the
eyes of the jury here yeah eric and my
final question to you i know that you
just mentioned the video evidence to
what extent did that evidence play into
the verdict i know we already talked
about how the jury requested to review
the video evidence before deciding on
that final verdict but you know
and again i know you just covered the
written house trial and you cover these
news events all the time to what extent
do you feel that the video evidence
really is making an impact on these
verdicts
uh you know it is
i don't even think it can be overstated
how important the video evidence is in
cases like this and i think it's been
said you know over and over again how a
lot of these cases that have become
central to the black lives matter
movement um have really uh gained so
much attention only because of the
evidence in the sense you've heard a lot
of people say um you know the only
reason people you know believe that this
kind of thing happens now is because
they have to look at the video and see
it of course that horrible video of
george floyd being murdered in
minneapolis it's sort of uh you know an
example of that uh so the video evidence
is just uh so crucial here uh you know
it's hard to watch um in for the jurors
i'm sure they had to watch it over and
over again um you know that final image
of mr arbory trying to sort of jog away
and then collapsing um onto the ground
so it's hard to say what might have
happened in this case if there have been
no video footage um you know we'll never
know but uh certainly a lot of things
like this that probably happened where
cameras weren't around
of course well eric really appreciate
you joining us to give us all the
context on this breaking news and i
should mention that we're going to
continue to have live picture from the
ground in brunswick georgia as we
continue to follow and cover the
aftermath of this verdict right here on
quick take again that was bloomberg news
legal reporter eric larson thanks for
joining us follow us on all quick take
social platforms on twitter facebook
youtube and instagram for more
developing news thank you so much